I come to you today to tell you that
Chris Christie's polling is now up
150 percent since he announced he was
running for president
however this puts him at two and a half
so listen percentage-wise things are
going in the right direction for Chris
Christie the the clearly the most sane
and rational person running in the 2024
Republican primary but is it going to be
enough I don't know so let's take a look
at some data Chris Christie announced
that he was running uh on June 6th but
we learned that he was running on May
31st June 1st so we're going to look at
how polling has changed for the
Republican candidates the top ones
between June 1st and today Trump for
example was at 53 when Christy announced
uh and he is now at 52. so Trump is down
two percent since Christie's
announcement DeSantis is totally flat
absolutely flat totally not woke at all
DeSantis was at 22 and he's still at 22.
so he has not seen any polling change
Mike Pence was at four but is now at six
pence has gained 50 percent Nikki Haley
unchanged four and four Tim Scott what
was it two percent now polling four
percent he has gained one hundred
percent support doubling it and then
there is Chris Christie who was polling
one percent
announced his candidacy and is now
polling 2.5 that is a gain of
150 percent
now am I being serious well I'm being
serious but I'm also going to be honest
with you about small numbers small
numbers in general can be inaccurate or
meaningless in exactly these sorts of
situations when you're looking at
changes because such small numbers can
be affected by rounding they can be
affected by data truncation they can be
affected by inflation context sample
size so for example if someone goes to
from one to two percent in polling it's
technically an increase of a hundred
percent you've gone from one to two it's
mostly meaningless because these numbers
are so small that they really may not
reflect the preferences of the
population and these small changes can
easily be influenced by random error
measurement uncertainty sampling bias
Etc so you do get rid of a little bit of
this by using averages of polls which we
are doing
is Chris Christie gaining I believe
Chris Christie is gaining but to say
that he has really gained 150 support
since his announcement
maybe is a bit further than we can go
what we are starting to get a picture of
and this is really important is that it
may not be so simple
to significantly shift massive amounts
of support in the Republican primary
Trump's now been indicted twice DeSantis
went from a potential candidate to a
real candidate Trump's basically flat
DeSantis is basically flat nobody else
is polling any more than six percent
so if there's any real takeaway right
now forget about oh they were at one now
they're at three or whatever the case
may be the big takeaway for me is that
it is proving difficult to see
significant moves in Republican voters
the next Milestone of course becomes
well number one does Trump get indicted
between July and September in Georgia
and number two in late August the first
Republican primary debate will take
place on Fox News Brett Bayer will be
hosting it does Trump show up to that
debate and does the debate performance
actually shift the numbers in any
serious way we have plenty of time to
think about that this is where the
polling is today we're going to take the
quickest break make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com the
davidpackman show and the show will
simply continue in a moment